all right
welcome everyone to the webinar three
the last webinar of of today's pause for
a cure
um it's my pleasure to introduce our
first
speaker dr adam resnick
he is the director of the center for
data driven discovery in biomedicine
at the children's hospital uh
philadelphia
and um i i've had the up the opportunity
and the pleasure to know
adam for a number of years and he is a
wonderful advocate for um for children's
research
and it's really exciting to see him here
at the paws for a cure event
and talking about canine cancer as well
as
as childhood cancer so with that i'm
going to turn it over to dr resnick
welcome everyone my name is adam ethnic
i'm from the children's hospital of
philadelphia
and today i have the privilege to really
present to you on behalf of
consortia-based efforts collaborations
and
a nih based initiative called the
gabriela kids first
data resource center and my hope is to
really go through
um both the evolution of some of our
efforts beginning with pediatric brain
tumors
and then the deployment and
implementation of platforms
how we look and think about
interoperability of those platforms
and more specifically how we hope those
efforts can really
um grow in the context of
canine based comparative research as
intersected with
opportunities for discovery in pediatric
cancer
research so
i couldn't really proceed without really
being transparent about my own history
and commitment
um to canines or dogs as part of my
family ever since
i was a child as you can see um i've
always had a penchant
for large buried dogs and also the um
you know probably shared belief of every
single owner that
um despite statistical uh
likelihood um
you know your pet will be with you for a
very long time
but unfortunately um like many dog
owners i
experienced you know the suffering
attributable to cancer initially with my
first dog this is me as a graduate
student
with thomas and saint bernard who only
lived a few years
and really succumbed to cancer
geronimo was a bernese mountain dog who
was with us between 2007
and 2014 and now we actually have
two really great amazing pups um
padfoot and navi who are great pyrenees
this is them in 2015 and this is
padfoot with my own um
14 year old um here
actually in 2019 so
we're our and who's been great
dog lovers but really our efforts began
in pediatrics with pediatric brain tumor
initially as a single laboratory and now
as a full-fledged center
here at chop i'm really focused on
how to address what
is the leading cause of disease-related
death in children
which is pediatric cancers and more
specifically
some of the worst are pediatric brain
tumors and recognizing very early on
that despite this appellation
it really is a rare disease context that
requires
rethinking about how to do research if
you want to change
any of these statistics associated with
really the suffering and
context of the disease that has
unfortunately not
wavered dramatically in the context of
new
drug development and therapies a lot of
this has to do with the need
of really thinking about collab
collaborative
or multi-institutional research
and how do you support the collection
curation of biosamples
across multiple institutions how do you
support large-scale data generation
integration accessibility and use of
those data
and here you can see really a timeline
of those efforts that began in 2013 with
four institutions
in the context of the children brain
tumor tissue consortium that has been
recently rebranded as a children's brain
tumor
network hence the cbtn
logo here but now today is more than 18
institutions strong and along the way
we've had to implement
a variety of different tools and
resources that
we think are equally applicable in the
context of
comparative biology research and
this is a uniquely opportune time to
pursue this
we don't just collect specimens and
samples and data for
their own sakes but really for clinical
translation and so early on
the children's brain tumor tissue
consortium or cbtn
really began partnering with other
consortium-based initiatives like the
pacific pediatric neuro-oncology
consortium that together really
represent
more than 30 institutions across the
united states
europe australia and asia
dedicated to really continuing across
biosample collection
large-scale data generation analysis
interpretation and clinical translation
in the context of biological
biologically relevant clinical trials
the bar repository based efforts really
now are fairly robust with more than 3
500
subjects included or enrolled in the
repository
more than 45 000 biosamples and an
initial set of about a thousand whole
genomes
and rna-seq across all histologies
we recently had the privilege of working
with the nci uh
cptec group on a pan histology
proteomics study
as well as a single cell
study so really creating multimodal data
for
analysis of disease in ways that we hope
then can drive new biological
understanding
and its implementation in the context of
clinical trial development
to make this work uh across institutions
a sequence asynchronously in a way
that's engaging
both scientific interests and clinical
trial development interests
in real time unique platforms
and very early on we both borrowed and
stole
and mimicked things that dnh was doing
in the context of development
of cloud-based resources
by partnering with seven bridges in the
development of cavatica
workspace environment for um analyzing
genomic data
we partnered with the c buyer portal
team to develop pc bio
portal and more recently launched the
kidsfirst data resource
portal together these are environments
that provide for really
across-the-board engagement of both data
scientists bioinformaticians
engineers biologists like myself
in ways that you bring these two
communities these multiple communities
together
on behalf of convergence research to do
this you really have to have a modular
approach that brings together
these tools and resources in an
efficient way
across the workspace environment that
support non-local access
use integration new data sets portal
environments that can empower our users
to discover those data sets across data
modalities
knowledge bases that integrate process
data
for hypothesis generation
integration across molecular data sets
and clinical or phenotypic data
a more recent effort that allison heath
and our team has been leading
with the nih fire working group
and then really in the context of
pediatric where multiple
institutes and centers generate data
interoperability across those data
resources at the nih as supported by
for us strides in aws a program that
really
empowers cloud-based compute storage and
analysis
this provides an end-to-end approach
that not only transforms
samples to data to information to
knowledge and hopefully impact through
really an iterative cycle
but that double funnel of both uh
integrating multiple different data
types across multiple different samples
and
hopefully multiple different contexts of
both human
and non-human disease and then also
integrates at the other side
the human element of discovery across
different domains
this really came to fruition building
upon the kids first efforts
with the sorry building upon the
brain tumor efforts with the launch of
kids first which really was
a unique program by the nih that sought
to intersect for the first time
pediatric cancers
and structural birth effect defects
recognizing that
really development is a unique context
for disease
that might have shared biology in ways
that could be
approached through large-scale data
generation
there's been more than 30 different
studies to date with
more than 30 000 whole genomes sequenced
across a large number of very variegated
diseases
and our hope is that this provides a
platform to then further
intersect in the context of comparative
biology through
approaching canine cancers
this of course should not be unusual to
any of the audience but i think it's
worthwhile sort of noting this
context of both structural structural or
congenital birth defects
and cancer is not unique to childhood
it's
actually also present in every one of
these breeds each one of these numbers
is really representative of a congenital
or
heritable disorder really representing
the same type
of intersection that we see in
pediatrics
and several recent studies especially
have noted
registered-based studies have noted this
intersection
with the risk of hazard or
is hazard risk increase
for children who have either cancer or
structural birth effect for the other
it's within that landscape of both
platforms data sets
pediatric cancers and especially
pediatric brain tumors that we sought to
really
recently develop these further really
using the same approach we did in
pediatrics but um
leveraging them on behalf of new efforts
in canines
so we partnered with rebecca molly and
nicola
and the tgen team to really begin some
new data generation efforts
in pediatric sorry in canine brain
tumors across histologies were just in
the beginning of these efforts
and at the same time focus on ways that
these efforts could scale
um in the future uh by creating
reproducible um workflows in
the kavatika platform leveraging what
we've done for kids first but bringing
it to bear
in the context of canine analysis such
that those workflows um with the
appropriate genome bills can be
reproducibly used for analysis of
integration across
data sets not just those that we
generate but those of others
and that's been for us a recurrent theme
the need to really think about data
that's generated across
an ecosystem and bringing that data
together it's not
uncommon for different data sets in the
pediatric context to be generated
under different programs in different in
institute centers
and the need to interoperate across
those we've had the privilege
as part of an nh interoperability
initiative to really work with
nhlbi and the gri ncbi and nci
to really drive those interoperability
across platforms and our hope is to now
extend this in the context of the
integrated data commons
indeed you can do this now uh you can go
to the integrated canine data commons
select data sets
and bring them into kabatica likewise
you can do
this with let's say roles data in dbgap
and very shortly you'll be able to do
this in a much more seamless way by
simply taking your manifest of interest
and um uh imported
the data into combatica the very same
way that you can do this now
with the ketchup genomic cloud in part
leveraging our partnership
with uh seven bridges this provides for
users the capacity to then take these
diverse data inputs whether it's data
that we newly generated with partners
existing datasets they've already been
published on or or they're in the part
of the canine data commons
and begin to intersect them with the
pediatric context
looking for that intersection across
either
pediatric brain tumors and canine
brain tumors or even expanding beyond
that
particular histology as we move forward
and then taking those data
and likewise leveraging the downstream
workflows tools and environments that
are available
in addition to genomic molecular data
what we've learned
you know time and time again is that
paired with biology
um at the molecular level uh you can
really empower discovery by bringing in
clinical and phenotypic
data this has been a fairly steep
challenge
in the genomics context
with really two communities operating
independently the clinical informatics
teams oftentimes working
independently from the bioinformatics
teams
we sought to really try and create the
uniform environment for this by
in kids first um and again as part of
uh interoperability efforts across the
nih implementing
fire based resources and uh
including then omap interoperability um
and then more recently have engaged the
tufts
team and t-gen once again to look for
ways
that really leverage what they have been
doing in the context
of the canine clinical trial landscape
and the deployment of omap
in ways that can further intersect
across not only genomic and molecular
data harmonization but also clinical
data harmonization and we hope that
bringing these to bear together
and as you can tell some of these are
still fairly nascent just beginning
efforts
but bringing this together across new
data generation
existing data sets platforms that can
inter-operate
with new resources that then span both
the molecular and clinical context
we can open the door for accelerated
discovery on behalf of both children
and dogs and brain tumors for us really
provide
a unique unmet need for both drug
development
the modeling of the immune system the
addressing
of the blood-brain barrier and the
development of new therapies
and we hope really sincerely to expand
these collaborations
leverage existing and shared resources
and ways that we can interoperate across
these efforts
on behalf of accelerated discovery
thanks so much for your time
and for listening and i look forward to
really
partnering in any context pediatric
canine or otherwise and everything i
just spoke
about is available presently and
open for use and access within the
kidsfirst data resource
so thanks so much and i look forward to
the rest of the meeting
all right that was really wonderful adam
thank you so much for
for your presentation something i forgot
to mention at the beginning is
if you if those are in the audience you
have questions please type them in the
in the question the q a bar and uh
we'll make sure when we get to the the
discussion section that we
we ask those questions so if you you've
got thoughts right now things you'd like
to be able to ask adam
please put them in the in the q a
section and and we'll
we'll answer them when all the
presentations are are complete and
hopefully a little bit of a a panel
discussion um
so i'd like to now introduce our next
speaker
it's my pleasure to introduce dr connie
summers
at the nci in the division of cancer
treatment and diagnosis
she is in the developmental
developmental therapeutics program
um and she's the program director in
the the uh the immunotherapy
oncology branch and and
dr summers has been working for a number
of years
in immunotherapy and in particular and
in canine
um immunotherapy and you're going to get
a chance to hear um some of her work
directly from her
dr summers
good afternoon i'd like to thank all
ricky and the organizers of this meeting
for inviting me
to speak about nci resources for canine
comparative oncology
and specifically about the integrated
canine data commons
i work at the division of cancer
treatment and diagnosis and
nci and we support cancer
research and canines to define the
utility of using dogs as a translational
model
for human cancer therapies and we've
done this at three different levels
first in 2016 at the genetic level we
funded
cancer center grant supplements to
investigate the genetic
basis of multiple canine tumor types
and then in 2017 we funded five
research project grants along with a
coordinating center
in conjunction with the cancer moonshot
project to initiate cutting-edge canine
immunotherapy
trials and correlative studies and i'll
mention these two efforts briefly
then i'll concentrate more on the main
event
for comparative data analysis which is
the icdc
which we created to provide publicly
available
database that can be asked for
comparison of
canine cancer data with human cancer
data
so first the the supplements to cancer
center grants
were awarded in 2016 there were eight
one-year supplements to support research
in canine cancer research via
collaboration
between nci designated cancer centers
and veterinary medical colleges the kind
of research that was supported
was mostly for sequencing this was whole
exome and rna sequencing and each
supplement
was for to sequence at least
25 k9 tumors and their normal controls
and there were a variety of tumors that
were investigated b cell lymphomas
gliomas
osteosarcomas melanomas bladder cancer
and mammary cancer so these were
initiated a few years ago they're
starting to bear fruit
these are just two examples of papers
on the bottom you can see from debbie
knapp
a paper that utilized data
that was generated from the p30
supplement
in bladder cancer and then on top
from roland verhack there's a
this was partially supported by the
p30 supplements looking at canine
and human gliomas and um
what he found was that the canine
gliomas were most similar
to human pediatric glioma so these are
some of the studies that are just
starting to come out
they're partially based on these
supplements
so the second effort was cancer moonshot
the canine immunotherapy trials and
correlative studies
so this network called the self-precinct
or pre-medical
cancer immunotherapy network for canine
trials
it's been a collaboration between the
national cancer institute and the
coordinating center
at the university of pennsylvania and
then there are five different
research groups which are seen on the
right hand side of the slide here
and you will recognize that some of
these investigators have been speakers
at um at this conference
this has an overview of the kind of
research that's being done and the kind
of therapies
that are being utilized here you can see
different investigators that are looking
at brain tumors lymphomas
osteosarcomas and melanomas and then in
terms of therapy
there are tumor microenvironments
modulators
there are cytokine therapy autologous
cell therapies like nk cell therapy
there's a vaccination approach with
tumor lysate
checkpoint inhibitors like a novel
checkpoint inhibitor cd200
oncolytic virus therapy and then a lot
of
combinations of these different
therapies
so in terms of you know where where was
this data all going to go the
genetic data the
clinical and correlative data from from
precinct
uh we wanted this state these data to be
publicly available
so the dctd charged the frederick
national laboratory for cancer research
to build that integrated canine data
commons or icdc
which is a cloud-based repository of
canine cancer data
it was established to further research
on human cancers by enabling comparative
analysis with canine cancers
the data in icdc are sourced from
multiple different programs and projects
but they are all focused on canine
subjects
the official launch of the icgc was
august 26 2020 which is also
national dog day and you'll be seeing
this website
several times during my talk
caninecommons.org
that's where data can be accessed
from itvc so what types of data can be
submitted
so of course there's descriptive case
data like breeds sex
diagnosis stage of disease there's also
genetic data
like genomic and transcriptomic data of
course
clinical data clinical responses adverse
events
we'll also house imaging data like
pathology pathology
x-rays pet scans and other scans
and you know phenotyping data can be
submitted that can be like eliza's or
links to flow cytometry
and then as i'll describe we're making
the system flexible so that there are
other kinds of data that you would like
to
submit we'll also be able to accommodate
that
icdc is part of the larger cancer
research
data commons and this is a large
ecosystem
and i'll concentrate here on the
different uh
commons in the system you probably are
familiar with the human genomic data
commons
and then some newer ones like there's an
imaging
data commons clinical trial data commons
and of course what we're focusing on
here
the integrated canine data commons
the icdc data model is based on
neo4j graph database and as i
just mentioned there's a flexibility to
add new nodes and properties
so we can put in new types of data
if that's indicated it allows for
both clinical trial type studies as well
as
molecular characterization type studies
and users may search across the entire
system
using a faceted search or through the
api
the data model model is available at
this link listed here
and also a visualization of the nodes
and properties
is available at this link listed on this
slide
in terms of workflow the data that
you start with will be curated and
harmonized
and eventually transformed so that it
can be compared from study to study
without any trouble
so then the transformed and finalized
data
goes to the user interface which is the
website
and this is a screenshot from the
website
i'd like to focus your attention to the
left you can filter
by study by study type by breed by
diagnosis so you can really
pull out what kind of data that you want
if we look for example here at breed you
can also
hover over different sections and you
can see
how many cases of a different breed we
have and
decide exactly what you would like to
focus on for your analysis
and then the analysis will be done
outside the icdc but there will be
links and helpful information to help
you get started with that analysis
we will be linked to a number of
different
um different ways
of helping you analyze your data for
instance the cancer genomics cloud
by seven bridges um can help with
an analysis of sequence data in many
different ways
for what kind of queries is icdc a
useful resource
i've just come up with a couple of
examples here of course this is not
inclusive hopefully you can think of a
lot
more but if you look at a specific
cancer type say glioma
if you want to look at a certain
mutation in a certain genetic region of
interest you can say is that specific
for
a group of breeds like boxers bulldogs
and terriers versus all other breeds or
compare
individual breeds compare really
whatever group you want for
for a mutation or a region of interest
that you're interested in
another application might be if you want
to look at
a particular disease type like canine
mast cell tumors
and ask are they more similar to human
melanomas
or to human mast cell tumors or to lung
tumors
as long as you have the canine data and
the human data
that you can access to do those
comparisons
that would be somewhere that you could
go with this
um in terms of therapy does treatment
with drug x then cancer type y
shows similarities in dogs versus humans
so if you have the same dog
or a different drug and you have you can
find the data for the humans
you can compare for instance clinical
responses
you can compare if you have histology or
immunophenotyping
if you fill in for infiltration you can
compare tumor micro
environment composition you can compare
different
pathways of gene expression um really
you know what it whatever you can find
hopefully uh you can compare and and
this will put us farther along
the track on determining how good
the dog is as a model for particular
human cancers
and how much we can do in dogs that will
inform therapies for
for humans but really we're interested
in what kind of queries
would you like to use the icdc for
um so hopefully in the panel discussion
part you can
let us know um what you what you're
interested in
what kind of questions you would like to
ask and then we can
try to make sure we can accommodate that
here's a list of some studies that have
already been submitted to icdc
and there are a number of different
disease types as you can see lymphoma
glioma bladder cancer
one thing i'd like to point out here if
you would like to submit data but you're
not ready for it to be publicly released
you can go ahead and submit it and we
can embargo the data
until publication or or until
any date that you wish so we're trying
to be pretty
flexible with this system that there's
something that you need
please ask and hopefully we can
accommodate you
so how do you access data in icdc
again here's the website
caninecommons.cancer.gov
and how do you submit data you go to the
same
website and here's the link for how to
submit data
and if you have questions about
submitting or any other aspects of the
icdc
please email us at icdchelpdesk
mail.nih.gov with your questions or
comments or suggestions
lastly i'd like to acknowledge a number
of people
who have helped in the icdc
effort first toby head from the nci who
was
who helped initiate these k-9 research
programs at nci and as a guiding force
all along for all of these efforts amy
leblanc
who's in the intramural nci program who
is a great
advisor on all veterinary issues to us
andrew singh who's in the immuno
oncology branch where
i am also erica kim
who is at cbit and helps us with the
data part
of these efforts matthew byers
is from frederick national labs and he's
giving a poster at this
meeting so please go to his poster
presentation
and he can help you with some of the
more technical
aspects of icdc also
john otridge is from frederick national
labs and oversees the icbc
and other data efforts and
he will be in the discussion following
this session
so he can also be available to answer
your technical questions
and lastly i'd like to thank debbie
knapp who's the chairman of our icdc
steering committee and you'll be hearing
from
after my talk and really all of the
members of the icbc steering committee
from the extramural community
um we're really grateful for all the
health input advice that you've given us
to try to make this
a user-friendly and useful resource for
for the extramural community i'd like to
thank you for your time and attention
and i look forward to the panel
discussion time
and your questions thank you
all right thank you connie that was a
wonderful talk and obviously i had a
little bit of a brain glitch that was
all about the icdc
and i apologize for the wrong
introduction there
um again i want to encourage everybody
to put their questions down in the q a
so we have we have your questions um
otherwise you'll be stuck listening to
my questions and i'd much rather ask
yours
so we have one more presentation from
from dr deborah knapp and as you heard
from
dr summers she is the chair of the icdc
steering committee but of course she's
much more than that she's a
she's a dolores ella mccall professor of
comparative oncology
and the director of the purdue
comparative oncology programs
she's a professor at the at purdue
university
um and she is a uh
a uh doctor of veterinary medicine so
with that i would like to introduce dr
knapp and you will get to hear
some of her thoughts on the power of
comparative oncology
good afternoon the title of my talk is
genomic characterization of canine and
human invasive bladder cancer
lessons and opportunities for adult and
pediatric cancer data integration
i'm debbie knapp i appreciate the
opportunity
to participate in this meeting and share
some of our work with you
if we think about how are we going to
make advances
in the management of cancer in dogs and
in humans
we have to make progress on three fronts
the first is on better therapies we need
more targeted drugs
immunotherapies drugs we honestly
haven't even conceptualized yet
and combination therapies we also need
to be able to select the patients
that we know will respond best to
specific drugs
and we ideally need to make progress on
cancer prevention
although i'm going to use an example of
an adult cancer
that is invasive bladder cancer these
processes apply
to pediatric cancer as well as to adult
cancer
and in both adult and pediatric cancer
we need highly relevant animal models
because they're not enough human
patients
and not enough money to test all of the
new strategies
that we may want to evaluate it's been i
think two years ago i attended a human
bladder cancer meeting and one of the
speakers put a slide up
noah han from johns hopkins a very
compelling slide
and he outlined all of the new
strategies that we should test
in humans and then when he added up the
number of trials it was going to be
something like 36 new trials
and there just aren't enough resources
to do all the trials that
want and that makes pre-clinical or
pre-human work
in animal models very very very
important
so dogs can fill this niche because of
the relevance to the human condition
and related to the topic of the the
discussion here
genomics really are key
the example i'm going to use is invasive
urinary bladder cancer it's also called
invasive urothelial carcinoma it's also
called transitional cell carcinoma or
tcc
and this disease in dogs and humans is
very similar
in the clinical presentation in the
pathology
and in aggressive cancer behavior it
invades into the bladder wall in at
least half of patients both dogs and
humans it spreads to distant sites in
the body
this cancer in dogs and humans is also
similar in molecular features
and specifically i'm going to focus in
on what's called molecular subtypes
this these subtypes are defined by rna
seek or by expression data they were
first identified in human breast cancer
but they're also present in human
bladder cancer
and the reason we care is these subtypes
affect how the cancer will behave
and how it will respond to therapy or
not
across several studies in humans really
worldwide studies
there are consistent findings of two
major subtypes they're called luminal
and basal
and the luminal tumors tend to be less
aggressive
and tend to respond better to targeted
therapies
whereas the basal tumors tend to be very
aggressive with early metastasis
frequent metastasis but interestingly
they may respond better to chemotherapy
and respond better to immunotherapies
and so these subtypes are really
important in being able to move toward
personalized or individualized care well
these subtypes exist
in dog bladder cancer and i'm going to
use this heat map to demonstrate the
point
the way this map is set up each column
represents
one case and each row represents one
gene
and the expression of the gene goes from
green which is really underexpressed to
red which is highly overexpressed
the way the heat map is set up the
columns under the green heading or basal
tumors
in the columns under the yellow heading
are luminal tumors
the gene set that was used to create
this
heat map is the same gene set that
classifies human bladder cancers luminal
and basal
and i think you can appreciate how the
color patterns really do distinguish
these subtypes in
in the dog cancer as well
one of the other things that's really
important about these subtypes
and really fits into the the huge wave
of immunotherapy that we're all seeing
is that the immune component of the
tumors
differs between the luminal and the
basal subsets
so in this heat map again each column is
a case and each row is a gene
and the green columns are the basal
tumors and the yellow columns
are the luminal tumors except the genes
in this heat map
are a panel of genes that use is used to
classify
human bladder cancer as either immune
hot or immune cold
and by immune hot i mean that it's
inflamed
it has infiltration of t lymphocytes it
has pro-immunologic signatures
on the other hand immune cold means the
tumor is not infiltrated by immune cells
and it has immune suppressive features
in this heat map the way we set it up is
that the red
boxes are going to represent
pro-inflammatory patterns
and the green boxes are going to
represent the immune suppressive
patterns
and i think it's very very obvious that
the basal tumors again those under the
green headings
are immune hot and the luminal tumors
are immune cold
so now this offers us the opportunity to
actually select
tumors for for the study that we want to
do so if you want to study a strategy
to convert immune cold to immune hot and
you'd want to do that because immune hot
tumors are much more responsive to a
variety of therapies
you could study the luminal tumors in
dogs on the other hand if you're already
to go with an immunotherapy
you would want to pick the tumors the
basal tumors because they are already
primed
to respond to an immunotherapy
so connie in the talk right before hours
gave
a really good overview of the mci's
integrated canine data commons or icdc
we are depositing two bladder cancer
datasets into this common
and one of them builds on this lumino
basal subtype
work and i can tell you that with
approximately twice as many cases as the
ones i've just shown you
the results are even more compelling the
subtypes
are are definitely apparent and the
immune infiltrates within those subtypes
the data is just
even more compelling than what i've just
showed you
so again this gives us the opportunity
to begin to study personalized care
by selecting the patients i.e the dogs
that have not just the subtype that we
want to study but the immune type
if i could go back now to the title of
the talk i'm supposed to cover
lessons and opportunities so let's do
that
and let's start with opportunities
because that's what i get most excited
about
so this is the same slide i showed you
earlier this is where we need to make
progress
on the three fronts and i am absolutely
convinced that dogs are going to help us
do this
and that genomics is going to be a key
piece to this
because we have the opportunity in dogs
to study these new therapies
we have the opportunity to to study
personalized strategies such as the
subtype so we can build on that with
much more
with the genomic signatures and based on
the high
breed associated risks for bladder
cancer in dogs
we have unique opportunities for
prevention research
but that's for another day in terms of
the lessons
i'd like to mention two things these
reflect
my thoughts on this whole field recently
first of all
we need all models even though i am a
champion for the dog models
we need everything we do need the
experimental models they provide
the opportunity to do studies in a very
tightly controlled environment
they offer opportunities to do
mechanistic studies
so we need those i am in no way
suggesting that we do away with any of
the bottles
rather i think dogs will complement
those because the tumors and dogs are so
much more similar to those in humans
than some of the rodent
models so my second lesson is
genomics are really key because they
will allow
us to use dog tumors for a variety of
different reasons
so one of the interesting things about
dog bladder cancer
is that the majority of cases express a
mutation in the braf gene
it's fascinating it's the same gene the
same position on the
the gene and the same substitution that
occurs
in eight percent of all human cancer and
so
this means that people that are
interested in this b
raph mutation may tap into dog bladder
cancer
for their studies this would include
people studying metastatic melanoma in
humans because that's where b
raft mutations are perhaps most
important
so now not only do we have a bladder
model but we have a model for
other types of studies on the other hand
if you want to study the subtypes
related to bladder cancer the dog is is
ideal for that because you have the
subtypes
and what i think is interesting is that
even though b-raf mutations are common
in dogs
they're not that common in human bladder
cancer
in the more advanced really aggressive
tumors yet we see it more
but across bladder cancer in humans are
not that common
and so i think it's fascinating though
that the subtypes are still persisting
even though different drivers may set it
all in motion
so i'm really excited about
where the field of comparative oncology
is going where the genomics is allowing
us to go
and i think it's just it's an ideal time
to be working in this area of research
and i'd like to thank you for your
attention on this slide
i'm showing some of the dogs that have
participated in our program
all all of them have bladder cancer
except the one in the upper right
and that's my own dog and i also have to
say
i feel very very fortunate to work with
with so many
very very talented people i want to
point out dr
dewan who who did a lot of
bioinformatics work
and led a lot of the subtyping studies
in our group
and at this point i'll be happy to pause
and
take any questions that you have thank
you
wonderful thank you so much debbie that
was a great talk and i loved you ending
on pause
um so um i i do have
so i'm gonna start with more of a
philosophical question then i'll get
into some other questions
um thinking about the
you know you imagine preclinical models
and
that evokes to me really the
the either cell models or rodent models
and and yet the the the
canine models are so much closer to
human
right because they are you know they are
spontaneous mutations they are
spontaneous cancers
is it fair to call them pre-clinical
models should we have a different name
for them
i'm not sure can you all hear me yes
okay cool um so
a great question i do think we
should call them pre-clinical models um
i i can certainly understand i can
certainly understand
um coming at it from different angles
though
and they definitely are a unique
preclinical model
compared to the others that
the scientific community is used to
working with
um perhaps others on the panel could
weigh in on that question as well
yeah i can speak a little bit about this
this is uh adam can you guys hear me
yes yep you know one of the things that
um
and one of the reasons i focused on
brain tumors is because one of the
biggest challenges for example
that we face in brain tumors and this is
true for both
adults and pediatrics is actually drug
delivery
and so you know the reason i bring this
up is because
um canines provide a model in which we
can assess drug delivery
um that overcome the challenges of the
blood-brain barrier for example so even
as we start thinking
about the context of models whether it's
the mutational context or the organ
specific
context the other is even just the
implementation or applicability context
and there is no other corporate model
whether it's
rodents or others that can fully
recapitulate
the challenges we face for example in
bloodbath barrier
overcoming so i think um that is
certainly
one of the ways that we think about um
the canine space
and alternatively i guess we could also
think that humans are the pre-clinical
models for canines that's certainly true
for be wrapped
that's a great point and actually
someone made a comment in the q a
that uh to call them true disease models
versus just pre-clinical models
so so you know it does bring up a
different
question and again uh debbie you you
were talking
a lot about about b rap so this is where
where my knowledge of of canine cancer
is isn't as great as i'd like
um so does the things like vemma
raphanib which are so effective in
melanoma do they work in dogs
that have these b-raf mutations the same
draft mutation
we have just completed a
clinical trial of bemerafenib in dogs
with bladder cancer
and the answer to your question is yes
the remission rate
is approaching 40 percent uh which is
as a true single agent that's better
than the other true single agents that
we have used so absolutely have activity
and acceptable acceptable safety
and one of the data sets you'll see in
the
icdc as soon as we can unembargo it
once it's uh in print or certainly in
press
is we have genomic data on
the from cystoscopic biopsies before
treatment
during treatment and at relapse and
we're able to
follow the changes in various pathways
which is very informative
and i think one of the more exciting
pieces of data coming out of the study
is that
we're seeing definite changes
in the immune state i.e tumors are
switching from immune cold to immune hot
when the tumors are responding and then
they're going back to immune cold
when the when the tumors relapse i don't
have all that information
right in front of me right now but i you
know where
we are um happy to share it with the
scientific community by publishing it
and putting it in the commons and and
hope others will
will mine it for additional information
as well
great that that's that's that's a
wonderful it does bring up another
question a follow-on question sorry
gabby i don't mean to pick on you
um thinking about the about b-raf
um again there are other human cancers
that have b
raf mutations b600d that aren't
responsive to them or affirmative
like uh most colorectal cancers for
instance
right it's actually pretty exciting to
think about now
looking at relapsed dogs and seeing what
pathways get
changed and does that correspond to
the the normal state of colorectal
cancer does that give us a different
key into the biology of colorectal
cancer
i think it can one of the things we've
done
is to look up the various pathway
alterations
that occur in humans that do not respond
to be raph inhibitors or those that
initially respond and then fail
and looking at pathways and looking at
specific genes there's a lot of overlap
between what we're seeing in the dog
tumors
and what's reported in people but there
are also some additional changes that
haven't yet been reported
um so it's
i think your question is intriguing in
that the response we see in dogs
is probably not quite as good as what's
seen in human melanoma and it does
appear better than colorectal and
thyroid so i think the dog tumors will
actually end up being somewhere in the
middle and hopefully that will be
even more provide even more information
that will help us understand
why do these drugs fail when they fail
because when they respond
people that respond have incredible
dramatic responses i mean people with
really advanced cancer
can have durable complete remissions and
and if we could help figure out how to
make everybody
experience that that would be wonderful
great we have a follow-up question
on on that point um
and this is from christiana orriston
um related to the vraft question i'm
wondering if the group can comment on
the
inclination to study canine cancers in a
histology directed manner
she'll be looking at tumors as all
comers and looking how they match to
human genomic genetic data
after the fact
i think we need to do something if you
want to answer that or somebody else
wants to answer that
my my response briefly is i think we
need to do both
i think we are starting out
most of the work to date has been done
on histologically defined tumors
but i think now have the opportunity to
define the tumors based on the genotype
and and so i think i think we need to do
both but please
others weigh in as well
and it might be different for canines
and for humans the histologies
and the connection to the genetics so i
think like you're saying we just need to
do them both and find out sure
and i think there are a couple of you
know coming from the pediatric space
where you know uh kids don't get cancer
because they smoke or they're
overeat or they're after sun too long um
and i suspect similarly there's an
element of
a previous position in
the context of canines that really
points to mechanistic
uh underpinnings that potentially
intersect with development or epigenetic
control where you do have
really tremendous capacity to penetrate
some of that
shared biology that might be
underpinning
at least in our case you know pediatric
and canine cancers
so from that perspective i think there's
you know a ton of potential
and then just to add you know another
couple of points um
you know oftentimes we don't get the the
privilege
of actually analyzing tumors after
therapy
in the human context or
when therapies fail what does a tumor
actually look like
after that you know it's very rare to
have
a sequential samples um
uh in this context again this is
something could be in a histological
sort of agnostic manner really powerful
to really think about
you know before treatment and after
treatment how tumors respond to therapy
independent of histology for example
just a couple of thoughts to consider
one of the things i i had on my slide
and forgot to actually
talk about was the precinct group
is putting together a nano string
platform
that will have immunotyping and there'll
be some genes in there for subtyping as
well
and one of the reasons that i'm
particularly excited about that
is it is a way to standardize how
you how you define the immune state
and we one of the
ways that our group plans to do it is to
determine if it works in urine because
if it does
then that's that gives you a tremendous
opportunity
to follow a lot of the information about
the tumor
over the course of treatment at multiple
time points so
mickey mason and others have taken the
lead on that and
we're really looking forward to test
that panel
um we have a nano a smaller panel our
groups put together that we know works
on urine but i think the one coming out
of precinct
will be even more powerful
yeah great thank you so we have another
question that's come in
uh now i'll read it it's from carol
robertson 12.
um the canine human bladder cancer work
that
dr knapp has conducted is a great
example leveraging target focused
comparative research
moving forward how is the best way or
what would the best way be for a
researcher that wants to
leverage the canine icdc and the human
cbtc for starting a new investigation
into relevant targets and dogs
a little bit of a complicated question
but really it's how do we take advantage
of some of the infrastructure that we've
invested in
to enable um new new
uh therapeutic research yeah
so maybe i can start and others can
chime in um you know i think this is one
of the
most exciting things that's been
happening um at the nih and nci level
um you know for us like theatre
community for example or the brain tumor
community we recognize that we don't
have enough investigators
that would care about pediatric brain
tumors so
many of our efforts around
interoperability
are to drive chance discovery um
and what i try to highlight in my class
in my in my talk is that
some of these emerging platforms and
their implementation provide for that
interoperability
where you know a user who might want to
create a cohort of data between brain
tumors and canines can bring them into a
common workspace
and do an analysis or
a portal environment can bring process
results from two different studies and
support that analysis
and i think the more we as a community
start doing those types of effort the
more
sort of the mimetic nature of science
will take over and others will do it
because it will drive
that chance discovery um you know for
example roles
you know in a really phenomenal study
showing that canine
gliomas share some biology with
pediatric
brain tumors is a perfect example for
the kinds of studies we want people to
do to then bring those two together
these those two data sets harmonize the
bioinformatic approaches
and deploy them in common environments
and expand that to bladder or any other
cancer
so my hope even after today is that you
know those types of efforts
um can take shape and we're certainly
happy from our side
of um the cbtc or brain tumor cohorts
or kids first to support these types of
efforts and working groups who want to
look at some of these comparative
biology questions
in some of these platforms
this john just add on to what adam said
is that
in his presentation it's very clear that
you can take the data
and analyze it in kovacica while
kovacica is built on seven bridges
genomics
which is based on amazon
and the icdc you can go and find cohorts
there and you find cohorts of interest
and you can bring them in
and you can combine them in seven
bridges
and analyze them and you can bring your
own data in there
also so i don't think that there's any
time soon we're going to have
one system to rule them all for
everybody
it's all about being able to enable
interoperability
the harmonization of the data is a
critical powerfulness
um as is the community aspects and
uh i think this um
aspect of adam did mention a little bit
about communities there's multiple
communities there's a canine community
and
helping the canine community understand
when we gather data can we gather it in
a way
that makes it more interoperable
downstream
not just for our own needs here can be
even more value extracted
from the samples that have been
carefully gathered
and i think these are the big changes
that we're seeing in the
cloud enables us all to come together
in ways that we haven't before across
not just genomics but also proteomics
and imaging
so i think it's really exciting with the
threshold of
so many of these pieces converging
together that we're going to have
an explosion of uh discoveries in the
next few years with the
funding on the grants as well as the
funding on the infrastructure
thank you john so we're just about out
of time actually a little overtime
um either debbie would you like to make
a comment and then connie i will let you
close this off since you had the middle
spot
in the and the presenting
i i'm not sure i have anything else to
add thank you
yeah and i don't really have much to add
too except i really um want to thank the
audience and thank the uh
participants and you know keep the
suggestions coming in
it really is an exciting time thank you
all right well thank you all it was it
was great to be here
and hopefully next time we'll actually
be in person
yeah thank you lauren thank you
everybody okay
take care